et au regard de ces images vous
comprenez déjà que le bilan de plus de
1000 morts et probablement provisoire en
ignore pour le moment combien de
personnes étaient dans ces maisons qui
ont été vous le voyez vous l'avez vu
fauché par la vague alors quelques
minutes avant l'arrivée de ce tsunami
sur l'archipel japonais c'est donc un
tremblement de terre qui fut le premier
signal de la catastrophe il a été d'une
rare violence je vous le disais 8° de 9
sur l'échelle de richter de longues
minutes ressentie à tokyo notamment
regarder ces images commentées par
julien duperey cette journaliste ne
finira pas sa phrase ils fuient sous les
6 pouces un immeuble menace de
s'effondrer
sauve qui peut dans les rues de la ville
de yokohama
sendai tokyo yokohama ibaraki le japon
vacille
natsu fotis deux minutes la secousse est
interminable
à sendai la ville la plus touchée
cette réunion tourne à la panique
passée la stupeur certains employés
préparer à ces situations se jette sous
leur bureau
mon souhait j'ai cru que j'allais mourir
c'était énorme et je comprends pas j'ai
jamais connu un tremblement si fort
gardent leur calme dans ce bureau de
tokyo
un silence déchiré par le bruit
inquiétant de l'immeuble qui tendent
dans les magasins les rayons
s'effondrent les uns sur les autres
effrayé cette femme tente de trouver la
sortie
lui fait rempart de son corps pour
protéger un vieillard ya dans chaque
maison
les murs tremblent les objets tombent
sur ces images amateurs postées sur
internet
les habitants se réfugie dans la rue
collés au sol dans un réflexe de survie